no it's wrong we're gonna need to start
again guys it's always unnerving to see
how actors can change their entire
personalities for a role and when that's
paired with an unbelievable makeup
transformation the results can be
mind-blowing turns out four hours in a
makeup chair is sometimes worth it from
prosthetics to airbrush and everything
in between who knew hollywood was full
of real-life shape-shifters when you
have a pair of horns on your head
you tend to view yourself very
differently daniel radcliffe has come a
long way from the bespectacled 11 year
old we all remember just take a look at
his transformation in the film horns
daniel plays igg a man who begins to
sprout horns and develop red fiery skin
after the demise of his girlfriend for
this film daniel wore a full body latex
suit a prosthetic cowl and face pieces
and wore makeup to blend it all together
while the majority of this look was done
using practical effects they did add
some finishing touches using vfx we
painted bright neon orange paint into
the cracks in the suit vfx was able to
add fiery lava to make it look like he
was burning from within in the end he
went from the boy who lived to a very
convincing demon
felt kind of trapped by this image
elizabeth created for herself you may
know margot robbie for her
transformation into tonya harding in i
tonya and while it was amazing she was
absolutely unrecognizable when playing
queen elizabeth in mary queen of scots
on the surface her makeup may have just
looked like a lot of white face paint
but below that were prosthetic smallpox
scars that margot spent three hours
every day getting applied while the
makeup was visually cool it didn't come
without its challenges it restricted my
facial expressions a lot however margot
was grateful because it helped her
really get into character and understand
the struggles elizabeth suffered through
holy crap
look at his face jacob trombley has had
a career that most adults can only dream
of when he was only nine he took on the
challenging role of auggie in the film
wonder it wasn't only draining because
of how serious the story was but because
of the prosthetics jacob had to wear
every day well it was pretty challenging
because the prosthetics i did have a
pretty serious role and it was emotional
and draining sometimes
the transformation took about three
hours but jacob was only allowed to work
a few hours on set each day they had to
rework the prosthetics and makeup
multiple times to cut the application
time in half but jacob didn't mind he
got to sit back and watch netflix the
entire time i had an ipad i binge
watched stranger things so that was
really fun
despite ryan reynolds humor about the
situation it's gonna be a really long
day today
getting transformed into deadpool wasn't
the easiest task they created and placed
thick silicone prosthetics onto his face
and head that were all strategically
hand painted with makeup the entire
process took four hours and had ryan
asking if there was any way they'd be
able to cut it down for the second film
lucky for him they cut it almost in half
so that they'd still have an epic
transformation and keep ryan sane
you're weak
i'm you
karen gillen's unbelievable
transformation into nebula was
considered the most complex and
interesting makeup process of the entire
guardians of the galaxy films her makeup
was basically one huge jigsaw puzzle of
prosthetics depending on where each
piece was placed it was either thinner
or thicker so that she'd be able to
still act karen even shaved her head to
make the process easier and that's how
easy it is to get rid of all your hair
once all the prosthetics were on the
makeup department went over everything
with airbrush paint and brushes in order
to fill any gaps and make it look
textured all in all it took three hours
to apply and another half hour to remove
johnny depp may have shot very few
scenes as grindelwald for fantastic
beasts but we got to see him in a whole
different light a very unrecognizable
light according to eddie redmayne no one
knew johnny was coming to set until he
was in full costume makeup and
prosthetics when they were wrapped he
cut and dyed his hair black before even
leaving set so that fans wouldn't
suspect he had anything to do with the
film
do you think you can hold me
helena bonham carter has played some
epic characters in the past but one role
she was unrecognizable in was the red
queen in alice in wonderland although
digital technology was used to make
helena's head seem three times larger
she also had to go through a vigorous
makeup process
she wore a bald cap that allowed them to
push back her hairline and make her
forehead bigger she also wore a
prosthetic forehead piece equipped with
wrinkles as for the makeup the
prosthetics were all blended in with
thick white face paint how dare you
oh for this head oscar isaac had some
major regrets when he realized just what
the transformation process was like for
his character apocalypse in x-men
apocalypse i didn't know
when i said yes that that was what was
going to be happening that i was going
to be encased in
glue and latex and in a 40-pound suit
that i had to wear a cooling mechanism
at all times i couldn't really move my
head the prosthetics he wore didn't just
go on his face but his entire body the
removal process wasn't any better oscar
says he would spend hours after rapping
getting the makeup and prosthetics
scraped off of him ouch
that was
x-men apocalypse the before and after of
dave bautista and drax is pretty amazing
the makeup artist constructed 18
prosthetic pieces that were made using a
map of his body they had created but his
prosthetics were super thin so that they
looked as close to skin as possible then
they would use makeup to blend the
prosthetics together for his tattoos
they had very large stencils that they'd
use with an airbrush the finishing touch
was the contacts that gave him his
piercing blue eyes that was awesome
richard brake's makeup for night king in
game of thrones was so distinguished
that the rest of the cast couldn't even
recognize him without his makeup i was
covered in prosthetics massive
fingernails literally the biggest
contacts you could put in a human eye
they were agonizing the entire
transformation process took multiple
hours and then the removal process took
another two hours but it got the job
done no matter how excruciating sitting
in a makeup chair for hours can be
it's pretty grueling no one would have
ever guessed that susan sarandon was the
actress behind the evil hag in enchanted
transforming into this character
involved makeup prosthetics dental
inserts and a fake hunchback underneath
her costume but susan ran into some
major trouble when she realized how hard
it was to express emotion beneath her
fake face and how to talk through the
fake teeth you'll love it you'll love it
halle berry played a lot of different
characters in cloud atlas but there were
three where she was absolutely
unrecognizable the first was an old
woman where makeup was used to age her
at least 30 years the second was a
character named aerys where she wore a
prosthetic nose dyed her hair and even
wore contacts the third was dr ovid for
him she wore a full head of prosthetics
and makeup it was so surreal that
halle's daughter was absolutely
speechless halle berry described the
whole process as chaotic
that part was thrilling as an actor and
a huge challenge
pennywise was a well-known horror icon
before the 21st century remake came to
be which meant bill skarsgard's
transformation into pennywise had to be
memorable and impressive not only was it
impressive but it completely transformed
bill into something else he wore one
large prosthetic and then makeup was
used to apply cracked skin and extend
his smile into a vertical one for the
first film it took them three hours to
apply everything but by the second film
they made the prosthetic 50 thinner not
only to cut down the application time
but to make sure that bill had an easier
time controlling his eyebrows and facial
expressions
i'm not afraid of you we will be
steve carell has a well-known face but
in the film foxcatcher his infamous face
became one that wasn't easily recognized
to become dupont he wore a prosthetic
nose tip forehead prosthetic and a fake
lower lip that changed the shape of his
mouth the makeup department also altered
his skin tone using makeup in order to
better match dupont's complexion the
cherry on top was the dark contacts he
wore to mask his bright blue eyes it was
perfect
long are the days where movie makeup is
more superior to tv in fact american
horror story has had some ground making
transformations including turning naomi
grossman into pepper naomi wore half a
face of prosthetics that included fake
eyebrows and then had makeup applied to
blend it into her actual skin she also
had prosthetics applied to her ears and
wore a set of fake teeth that changed
the shape of her mouth and jaw and i'm
turning the pepper
there's nothing quite like looking at
the before and after of an epic makeup
transformation sitting in the makeup
department for four hours may be a
grueling process but the end result is
oftentimes unmeasurable talk about
real-life shape-shifters what character
makeup do you think was the most
impressive